so in case you've been living under a
rock for the past month the saudi
government has officially announced neom
an ultra-high-tech region of the future
made up of trojenna and lsd user's idea
of a mountain resort the octagon the
floating surveillance dystopia and of
course the line the futuristic
line-shaped city cutting straight
through the landscape and we're going to
take a look at them now first trojana
which is a mountain resort on crack
complete with a huge concrete artificial
lake some bizarre mirror cave i'm sorry
i mean a portal connecting the digital
and the physical a vertical village
where people are transported by balls
some ultra luxury housing and the
world's most advanced healthcare and
wellbeing center to nourish both body
and soul now believe it or not this is
the least stupid part of neon and is
generally feasible if we leave out all
the bizarre shapes but as soon as the
saudi dictator wants something more
complicated than a mountain resort
things start going downhill pretty fast
enter the octagon a chimera of seaport
high-tech industry and residential areas
half of it floating on the sea 100
renewable energy fully automated seaport
clean advanced manufacturing research
and innovation buzzword buzzword
buzzword however this is a cognitive
city that not only adapts to your needs
but will learn to anticipate them it's
just a fancy way of saying you'll be
under constant surveillance by the saudi
state and i'm sorry you are building in
the open desert you have virtually
unlimited space at your disposal why is
half of this thing floating on the sea
blocking the way to your commercial
seaport and now you also run the risk of
having a cargo ship ram into your city
not to mention the damage severe weather
could do also are we going to invent
environmentally friendly cargo ships as
well because those are some of the worst
polluting vehicles on the planet
but the octagon still isn't the
stupidest part of this project that
title goes to the line it's going to be
so modern and futuristic that flying
pods will take you to your beheading
after the saudi religious place deems
you a blasphemer for sharing an article
about women's rights and believe it or
not its current iteration is a vastly
upscaled version of the original concept
which was basically three levels with
some buildings around the pedestrian
level but they only got more ambitious
with time so now the line is a 170
kilometer long 500 meter tall 200 meter
wide mirror plated skyscraper going
through the desert so what is wrong with
this project well what's not wrong with
it let's take a look
the project itself has some surprisingly
neat characteristics you're always five
minutes away from amenities two minutes
away from nature and there are no cars
or any other emission sources also the
whole project is set to be fully powered
by renewable energy and that's great but
they're trying to accomplish all this
with a 170 kilometer long hollow
skyscraper in the desert there is a very
good reason why we aren't building
cities in a line shape since you
needlessly stretch everything out so you
can be five minutes away from amenities
but if the immunity you want is on the
other end of neon well now you gotta
travel up to 170 kilometers to get to it
also the reason why they insist on a
line shape is because it's supposedly
more compact and prevents sprawling
which is a problem in saudi arabia but
sprawling only happens because of cars
cities that weren't built or bulldozed
for cars are all compact and space
efficient by nature so they could have
just built a car free city but that's
not futuristic enough so now we have the
line in contrast if the city was a big
cube or better yet a cylinder to achieve
the 34 square kilometer footprint
instead of cutting through the landscape
you would only need a 3.3 kilometer
radius structure i don't know if the tub
would feel as futuristic but if they're
all about efficiency that's what they
should be building not to mention the
tub would have less sides exposed to the
elements and you don't even need to drag
out utilities for 170 kilometers leading
to better efficiency by an order of
magnitude but once again that doesn't
feel futuristic enough so we have to do
the stupid version that does and the
problem with these pre-planned
monstrosities is they cannot account for
population growth they are inflexible
the line is supposed to have housing for
up to 9 million people what if the
population tries to exceed that will
there be a waiting list in a regular
city you can either densify or build new
districts with the line you're stuck
within the dimensions of your mirror
plated desert tube so if the population
tries to outgrow the 9 million mark
things will become unaffordable pretty
quickly but if the population declines
you're going to have massive abandoned
sections which you have to maintain
nonetheless you can just disable or
mothball them because that would cut the
line in two speaking of population
this whole futuristic space efficiency
looks nice on renders but it would
basically entail living on top of each
other in a confined space the
psychological effects of this would be
severe but at least this layout would
make it easier to hide from the
religious police aside from that since
we're building a city in 3d everything
also has to be accessible by low
mobility groups so we're looking at
systems of elevators and escalators that
take you up to 500 meters multiplied
along the entire length of 170
kilometers to give you an idea of what
this entails the empire state building
which is as tall as neom has to operate
73 elevators to move people around but
let's be charitable and say neon will
only need 20 elevators for a given
section let's also throw in 10
escalators for good measure suppose we
have one of these elevator escalator
systems every 500 meters that's 6 800
elevators and 3 400 escalators
yeah d vitamin deficiency is also going
to be an issue in order to get sunlight
you either have to live on the sunny
side or go all the way up to the top
otherwise life inside neon would be
rather depressing you're locked inside a
narrow tube full of buildings with
prying eyes on you potentially from all
directions at all times if you want to
catch a breather you can always go
outside though into the open empty
desert or you can take neo's
transportation system which is just as
smart and well thought out as the rest
of the project
[Music]
the planners i mean cgi artist's idea of
transportation inside the line is a
metro line a freight trail line and some
ultra high speed whatever running at the
bottom all along its entire length and
this is stupid for a number of reasons
first you have to build 170 kilometers
of subway and underground freight rail
so basically 340 kilometers of double
track rail tunnels in total and then
between those some kind of techno
[ __ ] rapid transit that takes you
from one end to the other in 20 minutes
so the thing would have to run at least
at 510 kilometers per hour not counting
stops along the way i've heard rumors
they want the hyperloop you know that
thing elon musk admitted to be a scam to
try to get california hospital cancelled
but here a regular maglev would also be
enough otherwise they would have pods
because of course they would and also
air taxis which has to be the stupidest
most dangerous idea of all running a
helicopter in a narrow semi-enclosed
space like that within close proximity
of public areas and housing so not only
will he go deaf from the noise and blind
from the rotor wash creating a tornado
of trash and dust you'd also get blown
down into the chasm if the thing doesn't
crash into the walls first due to some
erratic turbulence so you would be using
this subway for local transportation and
the maglev for long distance and this is
a problem since we're going in a
straight 170 kilometer long line if
there's any failure at any point your
system is immediately cut in half not to
mention necessary maintenance or
overhauls there would be complete chaos
this is what happens when you have a
single transit line serving millions of
people oh you want to ride the subway
sorry someone fell on the tracks 150
kilometers down so now 5 million people
are late from work and if you need to
get to the other end but the maglev
breaks down i hope you like traveling
200 stops on the subway for 5 hours
because that's what you're going to do
and these problems could easily be
solved if the line was shaped like a
regular city not a [ __ ] line in the
desert speaking of
if you look at any city on a map you'll
notice one thing it was either built
next to a river or on the coast even
cities like medina that appear to be in
the middle of nowhere are actually built
on top of oases as for the lion's
location there is absolutely nothing
there it's an empty desert meaning
things like food and water would need to
be shipped in from elsewhere and then
taken along the entire 170 kilometer
length of the line and just how do they
plan on going through that mountain
range will they dig tunnels underneath
will they excavate the mountain away
what if somewhere along the way the soil
is unsuitable for a 500 meter skyscraper
will the whole thing just sink into the
sand then and this whole fixation they
have on space efficiency would be fair
enough if they weren't trying to be
space efficient out in the open desert
where they have virtually limitless
space to expand speaking of there is a
huge open area right where the line
should end if they really want to build
the city of the future in the country of
the medieval they could just do it there
well actually the area isn't completely
empty neon is planned to be built on top
of the all art tribes territory so the
saudi government has already started
harassing forcefully displacing and
abducting them thus neo will stand on
the surest foundation there is genocide
but the line and neom as a whole in
their current forms are just not
happening here's why
on paper the neon project will cost 500
billion dollars that might sound
reasonable until you consider that the
price includes a mountain resort complex
with a mirror cave and an artificial
lake a half loading city seaport complex
and a 500 meter tall 170 kilometer long
skyscraper including 340 kilometers of
underground rail and 170 kilometers of
maglev for the sake of perspective just
the volume of the line is equivalent to
about 6 000 empire state buildings and
just one empire state building cost 572
million in today's dollars and the
letter was a regular building not some
techno magic hocus pocus fever dream
also regular skyscrapers as bad and
pointless as they are i have a video on
that have the advantage of being built
on top of pre-existing city
infrastructure in the case of the line
you have to build out all the utilities
and services from scratch plus hundreds
of kilometers of underground transit all
that is to say neon isn't getting built
out of 500 billion dollars by the saudi
dictator's own construction company mind
you and how this project would be paying
for itself is anyone's guess really but
hey indian and pakistani slave labor
provides a great opportunity for cost
savings and there are many more problems
i could list such as how would the line
be cooled how they would combat airborne
diseases in that lord semi-enclosed
space what if a maglev slams into a
structural element and the whole
structure just starts dominoing what
about the constant wind stress that the
structure would be subject to how would
water be provided for 9 million people
in the desert and so on of course the
overarching goal of this project is to
create a trade artery between saudi and
egypt bypassing israel which is fine but
they could do this very easily without
all the unsustainable techno [ __ ]
want to build a mountain resort just
build a goddamn mountain resort want to
build a seaport just build a goddamn
seaport want to build a sustainable
walkable emission-free city just build
one on the coast we know how to do it
we've been doing it for thousands of
years before cars took over our streets
and this is the tragedy of dictators
they can only think in terms of
megalomaniacal [ __ ] projects only to
serve their egos and provide huge
handouts for themselves and their
cronies the bigger and shinier the
project the bigger the ego and the
bigger the handouts that's the reason
why smooth brain dictator plus
construction project equals dumb [ __ ]
and neom is just the latest biggest
shiniest dumbest example of that oh and
by the way if i disappear after this
video please have the authorities treat
it as a murder thanks
you